[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio de luís méndez se louis en muy
buen día bienvenido feliz miércoles
iniciamos en escocia porque en el marco
de la cop16 el gobierno de reino unido
hizo importantes anuncios de que estamos
hablando luís raúl hay que señalar que
durante nuestra mañana el ministro de
hacienda británico richard un acto como
ya lo venía adelantando luisa pulido
informó que su país trabajará para
convertirse en el primer centro
financiero alineado con cero netos en el
mundo la posición del representante del
gobierno británico se sustenta en que
las empresas y los inversores buscan
sacar provecho del impulso para
construir una economía baja en carbono y
como parte de la iniciativa las empresas
que cotizan en bolsa así como las
instituciones financieras deberán
publicar detalles de la manera en la que
contribuirán para disminuir el
calentamiento global adicionalmente
anunció que sus países llenadas recursos
para ayudar a la financiación de
iniciativas climáticas en países en
desarrollo escuchemos
y durante los próximos cinco años
entregaremos un total de 500 mil
millones de dólares en inversión a los
países que más lo necesitan y podemos
hacer más hoy puede anunciar que el
reino unido destinará 100 millones de
libras al grupo de trabajo sobre acceso
a la financiación climática lo que hace
que sea más fácil para los países en
desarrollo acceder a la financiación que
necesitan reid
stein y luís y seguimos en europa porque
se dieron a conocer datos de desempleo
en la zona euro fue presentados por la
oficina de estadísticas y corresponden
al mes de septiembre
el dato se ubicó en 74 % una cifra que
refiere una reducción de una décima
menos dentro de la zona euro y hay que
comparar que el dato del mes anterior es
decir de agosto se ubicó en 7.5 por
ciento de igual manera la cifra
representa una caída de 12 por ciento
con respecto a los datos del mismo mes
en el año 2020 por su parte en la unión
europea la cifra de desempleo alcanzó el
67 por ciento dos décimas menos que en
el mes de agosto y pasamos a méxico
porque preocupación louis por los planes
de ellos vayan entregar subsidios a la
compra de autos eléctricos
raúl es que este país y otros tantos
firmaron un documento donde expresan al
senado estadounidense su preocupación
porque los subsidios destinados para la
compra de autos eléctricos como parte
del plan para reducir las emisiones de
carbono podrían generar problemas en las
producciones automotrices de estos
países a través de un comunicado los
países firmantes dejan claro que la
política más allá de resultar una vía
óptima para la protección ambiental
trata de manera discriminatoria a los
productores automotrices extranjeros
pero en méxico la situación se torna más
compleja porque de acuerdo con la
comisión especial de seguimiento a la
implementación del acuerdo tm que se
acuerdo que fue
modernizado hace unos años la situación
podría violar acuerdos alcanzados dentro
de este tratado louis ahora hablamos de
una de las grandes empresas de alemania
estamos hablando de la aerolínea
lufthansa porque reportó este miércoles
un retorno a las ganancias por primera
vez desde que se desarrolló la prenda de
kobe 19 el grupo reportó ganancias
ajustadas de 17 millones de euros frente
a una pérdida de 1.262 millones de euros
el mismo período del año anterior los
ingresos de la compañía en el tercer
trimestre fueron de 5.200 millones de
euros indicadores económicos tiene que
ver en este caso con los indicadores de
asia hay vacaciones en el mercado
japonés e pero en china las operaciones
tanto en hong kong como en ginseng
cerraron a la baja en el día de hoy por
la preocupación que existe en torno a
posibles bajas económicas en el futuro
por otro lado también en europa está
desarrollándose las operaciones con
cierres mixtos hasta los momentos
alemania y francia- registran cierres
positivos y muestran operaciones
positivas mientras que londres registra
números negativos y finalizamos este
primer bloque económico de la jornada
con la cifra el día tiene que ver en
este caso con los 9 millones de dólares
que cinco aerolíneas que internacionales
que operan en el mercado chileno deberán
retornar
a los turistas oa los consumidores en
este caso tras una decisión del servicio
de protección al consumidor de chile
louis gracias y ahora nos vamos directo
a glasgow en escocia y nos esperan
marina colorado y luisa poli vámonos
allá iremos